soir serge pin up merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france la tension qui
monte donc 1 à la frontière entre la
russie et l'ukraine vadimir poutine qui
parle de provocation dangereuse
pourquoi ce regain de tension selon vous
qui a rompu les accords de minsk
bonsoir voyez vous la situation est
vraiment dangereuse mais pour la
comprendre faut revenir quand même un
peu en arrière revenir dans l'histoire
en 2014 tout début 2014 les trois
puissances européennes à savoir la
france l'allemagne et la pologne
on compte signer l'accord entre le
président de l'époque victor
ianoukovitch et ladite opposition
un accord qui est passé dans la poubelle
ou moins de vingt quatre heures avant sa
signature le président a été destitué il
a dû quitter le pays et l'opposition en
monter un gouvernement des vainqueurs
au lieu de gouvernement de la cohésion
nationale sans que les garants du dit
d'accord ont leur mot à dire
presqu'un an plus tard en février 2015
les accords de minsk ont été signés les
accords dit winch 2 puisque en fait
c'était un document qui s'intitule
officiellement l'ensemble de mesures
pour l'application des protocoles de
minsk
un autre document signé quelques mois
plus tôt également garanti par la france
l'allemagne et la russie
hélas nos partenaires occidentaux se
sont montrés incapables de venir un
médiateur honnête dans ce jeu et depuis
le début depuis 2015 donc l'ukraine
esquive l'application de dix accords de
misc dès son retour à kiev en fait et
chien souligné tout particulièrement que
ce document de quelques pages
aujourd'hui tout le monde en parle mais
ça tourne à la folie des fois j'ai
l'impression que les gens qui en parlent
elles ne l'ont jamais vu quoi que ça ne
fait que deux trois pages doit maximum
d'ondés son retour à minsk et le
président prochain qu annoncé
que cet accord a été signé puisque le
crâne en avait besoin pour gagner du
temps que vous ferez d'ici un an nous
serons un état prospère tandis que john
bass sombrera dans la misère vos enfants
iront à l'école tandis qu'ebay leur
serviront dans les caves
etc etc etc depuis l'ukraine a fait
voter une quantité de loi qui
contredisent directement les clauses de
l'accord de minsk notamment la loi sur
l'éducation qui a banni du système
éducatif national russe et la loi sur
l'utilisation de l'ukrainien entend
qu'alinghi langues nationales tout ça ça
contredit directement les dits d'accord
il en est de même pour le retrait des
troupes et des armes lourdes de calibre
dépassant 200 mm de la zone de contact
ce qui n'a pas été respecté vous parliez
serre chevalier noir des pays
occidentaux les états unis en tout cas
montrent leurs muscles et envoie deux
navires de guerre en mer noire le
secrétaire d'état américain à la défense
anthony blinken sera de retour
d'ailleurs à bruxelles cette semaine
pour des discussions notamment sur la
situation dans le donbass clairement est
ce que vous vous craignez une escalade
oui on peut l'apprendre
on peut l'apprendre et vraiment c'est la
question qu'on devrait se poser qu'est
ce que font les navires américains à des
milliers de milles marins de leur
territoire au lieu de se poser la
question pourquoi les troupes russes se
déplace sur notre propre territoire
clairement quand la russie dit qu'elle
n'est pas une menace pour l'ukraine pour
les gens qui seraient sceptiques
qu'est-ce que vous répondriez
pourquoi veux tu ont estimé que la
russie soit une menace
la russie est un des garants des accords
de paix signés à minsk
il ya six ans la russie n'a jamais
agressé l'ukraine secrétaire général de
l'otan en tout cas recevra demain le
ministre ukrainien on lisait des
affaires étrangères à bruxelles
l'ukraine qui appelle l'otan accélérer
son adhésion pour envoyer un signal à la
russie c'est une ligne rouge pour moscou
vous serez ce n'est pas un mois de
prendre ses décisions mais effectivement
on devrait se poser la question les
exercices militaires de l'otan prévus en
ukraine à partir de mois de mai à quel
point correspond ça à un autre point
notre ami né à des hackers de minsk qui
prévoit notamment le retrait de toute
force militaire étranger du territoire
national alors la france elle a réagi
via un communiqué de presse du ministère
des affaires étrangères ça date de
vendredi dernier je vous propose de
l'écouter avant de vous faire région la
france considère important et urgent que
la russie puisse apporter de manière
transparente notamment par les
mécanismes prévus à l'ouest c'est eux
des clarifications sur le cadre et les
motivations de ces mouvements
nous soutenons la position de retenue et
de responsabilité affiché dans ce
contexte par les autorités ukrainiennes
la france poursuivra ses efforts
diplomatiques en lien étroit avec
l'allemagne dans le cadre du format
normandie afin de parvenir à la pleine
mise en oeuvre des accords de minsk ces
efforts restent indispensables pour
parvenir à une désescalade détention à
une résolution de la crise ukrainienne à
la france est suppose est médiatrice
dans ce conflit est ce qu'elle s'y prend
de la bonne manière
je crois que non il en est de même avec
l'accord signé en 2014 entre your chair
ianoukovitch et l'opposition
je crois que le comportement actuel de
l'ukraine suis de ce fait que les
garants de l'accord de 2014 n'ont pas
réagi à sa violation
aujourd'hui le cren se croient tout
permis y compris la violation des
accords de musc encore une fois je tiens
à souligner que les troupes russes se
déplacent à l'intérieur du territoire us
tandis que mes troupes ukrainienne
quoique en ukraine se trouve aujourd'hui
là où il ne devrait pas être en
application des accords de manière
c'est-à-dire dans la zone de 50 km de la
ligne de contrôle de contact dernière
question sur ce thème avant de passer à
un autre thème emmanuel macron doit
rencontrer son homologue ukrainien
volodimir zelensky les deux présidents
qui discuteront du déploiement récent de
forces russes après près de la frontière
avec l'ukraine
comment est perçue cette rencontre en
russie vous savez c'est une rencontre
aux deux chefs d'état là-dessus la
russie n'a pas son mot à dire
on va regarder les résultats mais nous
constatons que vladimir evans qui
multiplient ces derniers temps son
agitation sur le plan international
multiplie des contacts afin de s'attirer
de son côté le maximum de soutien
occidental qui n'est pas toujours
disons très honnête prêt prêt juste
alors autres grands sujets d'actualité
combien la crise sanitaire et la
vaccination avec le vaccin russe foot ni
lever qui attend toujours sa validation
à l'europe européenne du médicament pas
avant fin juin si on comprend bien
comment vous expliquez vous cette
lenteur où j'allais c'est pas nous à
l'expliquer dans le monde où
vivons aujourd'hui heureusement aucun
états au moins pour l'instant quoi que
les états unis ont fait beaucoup de
progrès là-dessus ne peut imposer un
autre état souvent l'utilisation ou la
non utilisation de tel ou tel produit
la russie n'impose rien va russie
propose le produit que nous avons un
vaccin scouts nique à savoir nous en
avons deux autres mais c'est le scoop
qui est produite en quantité aujourd'hui
qui s'est avérée efficace fiable et
relativement peu coûteux si l'europe on
à l'intérêt tant mieux sinon nous ne
cherchons pas à nous imposer
il ya souvent un argument qui revient la
capacité de production de la russie de
ce vaccin qui seraient moindres a
notamment selon la france
est ce que c'est le cas mais
effectivement nous avons la possibilité
de lancer sa production ensemble c'est
pour ça qu'une délégation de
spécialistes français s'est rendu à
moscou fin automne 2020 pour étudier la
production de
de ce vaccin les contacts entre
spécialistes ont été plutôt assez
positive maintenant nous attendons la
validation de notre vaccin par l' agence
européenne
en tout cas il ya d'autres pays qui sont
plus audacieux
l'allemagne en fait partie elle a ouvert
des discussions avec la russie sur
spoutnik v clément bonin le secrétaire
d'état européens a déploré un coup de
communication il estimé que la décision
était liée à la tenue outre-rhin des
prochaines législatives
qu'est ce que vous répondez en tant que
plus quand vous entendez ça est écrit
écoutez si les personnalités politiques
à l'occident cherche à utiliser le
vaccin spoutnik vais pour ce faire des
points dans leur jeu politique
intérieure cela ne peut que prouver ma
bonne qualité de notre médicament dont
nous ne pouvons qu être fier alors
emmanuel macron lui il va plus loin il y
voit carrément un outil de propagande je
vous propose d'écouter le chef d'état
français à la sortie du dernier conseil
européen c'était le 25 mars
l'europe et les chiffres qui ont été
citées par votre collecte tout à l'heure
le monde et le seul compte le seul
continent qui en plus exporte ses deux
seuls continents du monde libre qui a
une vraie stratégie vaccinale est une
vraie diplomatie vaccinale pas pour
aller faire du chantage à tel ou tel
pays et pour dire c'est un engagement
international qui est le nôtre et donc
faut être très clair nous sommes face à
une guerre mondiale d'un nouveau genre
face notamment aux attaques aux
velléités de déstabilisation russe
chinoise d'influencé par le vaccin d'
influence par le vaccin à une volonté de
déstabilisation les mots sont forts
emmanuel macron accuse clairement la
russie est ce qu'il ya des raisons vous
savez ce n'est pas un diplomate de
commenter le discours d'un chef d'état
de sur l'accréditation dont je ne peux
que répéter ce que je viens de dire tout
à l'heure la russie ne cherche à faire
chanter personnes la russie n'impose pas
son vaccin
la russie ne refuse son exportation pour
des prétextes politiques ou autres
la russie propose la coopération
sur ce plan là il la propose depuis
longtemps en tant que diplomate vous
avez peut-être quand même un avis sur
cette division qui commencent à poindre
enfin ça fait d'ailleurs déjà quelques
semaines
en europe on n'est pas forcément
d'accord notamment sur ce foot nick v
qu'est ce qu'elle dit cette division
selon vous sur l'état de l'europe
aujourd'hui vous savez des fois les
européens ont du mal à s'entendre entre
eux c'est naturel a lorsqu'on est 27
déjà à 2 parfois il ya des mésententes à
trois ça devient encore plus compliqué à
27 j'imagine même pas à quel point ça
doit et peut en faire de trouver un
compromis qui conviendrait à tout le
monde
heureusement je ne suis pas un homme
politique européen
dernière petite question ça concerne
l'école à la maison formidable école à
la maison l' enquête sur le plantage 1
du cid centre national d'enseignement à
distance le fameux cned
jean michel blanquer a immédiatement
dénoncé des attaques je suis venu de
l'étranger citant même la russie on
appris hier que selon l' enquête des
ordinateurs chinois et russes ont bien
été utilisés pour viser mais surtout pas
de conclusion active 1 on apprend que ça
ne serait pas forcément des russes même
si ce sont des ordinateurs russe votre
réaction à ce réflexe de viser les
russes dès qu'il ya un piratage quelque
part je vous dirais même plus vite
presque certain que ce sont mes gosses
ils sont capables à n'importe quoi pour
ne pas faire leurs cours ça doit être
sérieux pour être sérieux dans tout ce
qui se passe au niveau des de
l'informatique c'est un peu la magic
personne ne sera à vous expliquer 99% de
la population sommes comme vous et moi
nous ne comprenons pas ce qui se passe
au moment où on appuie une touche où on
fait bouger le curseur sur l'écran
à l'intérieur de cette machine magique
nous avons bon dialogue entre la france
et la russie au niveau des spécialistes
sur les questions de la cybersécurité et
je crois que
il ya des raisons viable est valable de
considérer qu' il ya un problème c'est à
eux d'en parler merci de l'ambassade
russe d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france